let's bring in our panel we'll start
there leslie marshall democratic
strategist jonathan swann national
political reporter for axios and former
education secretary bill bennett
jonathan
it's obviously night and day as far as
the speech and the message from
president biden to what we saw from
president trump and his uh address to
the united nations but it was
interesting that he didn't talk about
china or russia your thoughts
yeah
there was no mention whatsoever of china
or russia which
is notable given that the
administration is orienting itself
towards great power competition is
focused on asia there china was
referenced
in in indirect ways so he was sort of
putting out these non-confrontational
messages the big one you grabbed there
which was the
that we're not heading we don't want a
new cold war uh it was sort of trying to
lower the temperature he's got a real
problem with cha with the china strategy
that he's trying to pursue right now
they said their strategy sounded good on
paper it was this idea that we can
compete and confront china in all these
areas where we need to like trade but
we'll also cooperate with them on
climate change that's not how china
likes to operate and china sent a very
clear message to biden if you keep
talking to us about you know the
genocide in in xinjiang we're not going
to be sitting down with john kerry we're
going to be doing zoom calls with him
and we're going to be humiliating him
when he comes over here so that's
probably one of the biggest strategic
challenges they face
leslie it's been a bumpy few days maybe
a few weeks
for the bite administration for the
president on foreign policy but
domestically as well
what about this speech
i actually thought it was strong i
thought it was forceful and i thought it
had hope i like a lot of things that he
discussed regarding diplomacy i like
that he pretty much put it out there
brett that we the united states are the
ones that are going to lead the rest of
the world and this is so true uh through
climate change and through covid in
other words we need to work together we
don't need to have these unnecessary
wars we're going to be your leader and
in in a sense you need us and they do
the world does need the united states
and the world does
need our leadership i loved the fact
that he talked about sudan and belarus
and he talked about uh protesters there
and i liked the fact that i felt he
owned it and took responsibility he
didn't shirk it on afghanistan but he
didn't dwell on it too long in this
speech either you know billy it'd be
interesting to take a poll of what
countries think about the u.s in the
wake of the recent days and weeks but
there is a poll that came out today here
in the u.s in one particular state in
the state of iowa which obviously
factors into politics take a look at
this president biden's job approval in
iowa
according to the des moines register
poll
has dropped significantly
and obviously the situation at the
border factors in not just along texas
but around the country
well if he wants to continue to talk
about the protesters in belarus
and ignore russia and china
those numbers will continue to go down
look he showed up i guess he gets
credit for that by the way
and not talking about russia and china
then he talks and emphasizes i'm told
about climate change uh global warming
we used to call it but doesn't mention
china there either uh which of course
is uh is whistling in the wind if you
don't if china doesn't get do something
if we don't force or use our efforts to
get china to do something
nothing nothing better will happen
he doesn't seek a cold war but he's in a
cold war
somebody should tell him that he's
already in it
china must be very happy uh with that
speech the border is a disaster it is a
catastrophe and uh the human catastrophe
here of these 15 16 000 people
is just exacerbated uh by the
catastrophe of the secretary mayorkas
who says the border is closed you know
there you are you want to believe the
secretary of homeland security are you
going to believe your own eyes this is
ridiculous is there a breaking point on
this issue is there a breaking point
well it is interesting to watch the
secretary testify there were not a lot
of answers to senators both sides of the
aisle questioning mayorkis today but i
want to talk about this one image that
has taken
a lot of coverage in a lot of different
places and this is a border patrol uh
along the border dealing with these
haitian immigrants the vice president
weighed in uh others take a listen
what i saw depicted about um those
individuals on horseback
treating human beings the way they were
is horrible
and i fully support what is happening
right now which is a thorough
investigation to ensure control
of the horse long reigns are used but we
are going to investigate the facts to
ensure uh that the situation is as we
understand it to be any mistreatment or
abuse of a migrant is unacceptable we
are very troubled by what we have seen
uh jonathan quickly uh
border patrol is pushing back hard the
vice president's weighing in on this but
but hasn't been weighing in on the
border
well biden's in a very difficult
position because he's actually getting
hit by both sides at this point i mean
chuck schumer senate majority leader
came out and was pretty excoriating in
his comments about this
so bind's being hit by the left for
harsh treatment and he's being hit by
the right for the scenes that you're
seeing on the border